okay let's now get into this idea of the
narrative that the trumpets have been
crafting around the impeachment inquiry
and how it's been going so far and
allegations of illegal secrecy and stuff
behind closed doors warranting
Republicans barging in on a hearing
we're going to go through all of it and
in fact this week we've been doing a lot
of media analysis exposing how
propaganda cycles work about how those
propaganda cycles are often self
reinforcing like a feedback loop and
there are a lot of examples recently
that are really good ones that some of
the examples have been sillier so
earlier this week we talked about how
Fox News covered up the fact that Donald
Trump was booed at the World Series by a
crowd that was chanting lock him up
incessantly at Donald Trump less
important but still a good example of
how the propaganda cycle works but there
is a really serious example that we have
to talk about that's taking place which
is not about Trump getting booed and his
safe space being pierced this is an
example which potentially could be the
difference maker between Donald Trump
being reelected compared to Donald Trump
being removed from office okay that that
is how big the stakes are with this
example that I'm going to talk about
today and it relates to the
constitutionality and the
appropriateness of the impeachment
inquiry against Donald Trump because the
impeachment inquiry is getting more and
more popular and because it is being
formalized as soon potentially as
tomorrow by the House of Representatives
as I told you you are seeing Donald
Trump and his followers and his staffers
becoming more and more desperate in
their attacks against the inquiry itself
and their attempt has been to make the
impeachment inquiry appear to be a
completely extrajudicial
unconstitutional witch-hunt they've said
there's no due process well it's just an
inquiry and the resolution that was just
released outlines due process due
process comes during the actual
impeachment if it were to happen it
comes once there is a formal resolution
starting an inquiry with public
witnesses
and so forth they've said only Democrats
are involved in this inquiry
they're keeping Republicans out well
remember number one the impeachment
inquiry formally speaking hasn't yet
started but more importantly after those
Republicans stormed a meeting demanding
access we learned that many of those
same Republicans are already on
committees that are participating in the
inquiry and have been questioning
witnesses and allowed to review
documents it was a total farce the
latest one which I want to deal with
today is the idea that because things
are happening behind closed doors
something wrong is happening some major
injustice is taking place the truth is
plainly available and one person who
happens to be telling the truth may be
shockingly particularly since shepard
smith has already departed fox news and
he was often his guest is a former judge
and current fox news legal analyst
andrew napolitano
who explained hold on a second the
impeachment inquiry hearings going on
behind closed doors are taking place
consistent with the rules of the US
House of Representatives and he is
correct let's look at the video and then
discuss it the Judge Andrew Napolitano
so let me tell you what I did for you
kill me I read the house rules okay and
as frustrating as it may be to have
these hearings going on behind closed
doors the hearings over which
congressman Schiff is presiding they are
consistent with the rules they can make
any approvals they want well they can't
change the rules they follow the rules
and when with the rules written last in
January of 2015 and who signed them John
Boehner and who enacted them a
Republican majority now before we get
into the analysis did you notice what
Fox clown Brian Kilmeade did there
when Andrew Napolitano says they're
following the rules
the Fox clown says they could make
whatever rules they want and Andrew
Napolitano doesn't get on what get let
him get away with it he says no no
that's not the point they being
Democrats didn't make the rules
Republicans made these rules these rules
were signed into law by a Republican of
majority and it is Democrats now who are
following those rules
I like how Napolitano does not let Fox
Brian Kilmeade get away with it but
let's now get to the facts what we get
to is something I said earlier this week
if you do these interviews in public
possible future witnesses can watch the
testimony and then repeat the same thing
in order to appear as though they are
corroborating testimony and it can
potentially distort the investigation
and Napolitano goes on to also address
this issue of due process by explaining
these aren't the impeachment hearings
those would be public these are private
hearings to figure out who should even
participate in the impeachment hearing
secret evidence doesn't work in this
world so eventually there will be a
public presentation of this at which
lawyers for the president can
cross-examine these people and challenge
them this is like presenting a case to a
grand jury which is never done in in
public so I get it the Republicans are
frustrated and they wanted to make a
point and they made their point they
might have made it but but this is just
the not the most effective way to show
respect for what your colleagues are
doing I hope that you good people in the
audience understand what's going on here
Donald Trump wants you to think that
they are impeaching him in secret behind
closed doors without due process for
unknown reasons on the basis of
testimony that will never be made public
that's not happening okay what they are
doing is what police do when two people
might have committed a crime together
you separate the people you ask them
questions separately to see if there are
inconsistencies you ask them to recount
what happened without having the
privilege of seeing what their potential
co-conspirator is saying eventually once
the police figure out the case in a
trial they might question both of those
suspects in public as part of the trial
they might question one of them they
might question none of them this is a
choice that law enforcement gets to make
this is like criminal interviewing 101
and Donald Trump is counting on you not
knowing that and realistically even if
you know it a lot of Donald Trump
supporters
don't know it and it's working because
among his supporters that there is this
contingent of the believed Trump no
matter what he says crowd that has
fallen for this idea that there is
something unconstitutional going on that
there is something extrajudicial going
on that Donald Trump has been in some
way denied due process none of its true
none of that is going on here what's
happening is not even remotely unusual
don't fall for it
don't fall for it let me know what you
think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and coming up very soon this week don't
know exactly when but soon maybe tonight
live stream live streams are back on
twitch at twitch.tv slash david pakman
make sure you're following me there make
sure you subscribe with twitch prime if
you are an Amazon Prime member quick
break back after this